Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 21st FUWAMOCO Morning!
Wow.
I'm excited.
21st?
22nd?
I feel like we'll be at 100 soon.
It hasn't been very long to get to 21, so you know 100 will be here before we know it.
Right.
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us.
But for any new Ruffians, please let us introduce FUWAMOCO Morning.
One minute early.
Huh?
Are we a minute early?
No?
Yes?
Yes.
This is what happens when I let Fuwawa look at the time!
No, Ruffians, you're joking.
Yes.
Well, to explain, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Moco-chan.
Why is it Friday, Wednesday, Monday?
Yes.
Cause that spells FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
I just kind of started out on a bit of a... It's still on my paw!
It's just a bit different.
Different fingers on the paw.
Different finger we started with.
Ruffians, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians,
I wonder if there's been... There has been!
Is it a question?
Let's see.
A rice field.
It seems like a Ruffian spotted Pero while they're working hard harvesting rice.
What do you mean Pero working hard?
No, the Ruffian was working hard.
Pero's never working hard.
That's so cool.
For you, Ruffian, not for Pero.
No.
But it does seem like maybe Pero just came out of nowhere and offered to help, though.
If he's actually helping, that's nice, I guess.
That's a bit unexpected of him, but... You know, maybe Pero wanted to experience something new, you know?
Like, last time, you know, he was driving the forklift?
This time, harvesting rice.
You know, it's kind of like a cultural experience, right?
You know, make yourself more of a
Well-rounded person, right?
Well-rounded person experiences, you know.
But it does seem that Pero kind of wanted to eat the rice and maybe was a little bit disappointed when he found out that he wouldn't be able to because it needs to dry for cheese first, right?
You have to dry it.
You can't just eat it and die.
Silly Pero.
But you know everything worthwhile takes time, right?
Yeah, yummy rice.
Oh, I guess, you know, we could say, uh, Pero.
Pero wa inekari shite ita.
Inekare wo shite ita.
Inukare?
Inukare shite ita.
You know what?
Use some of the new Nihongo that we learned in Kanji de go de yabete.
Ateru?
Ateru kana?
Is that right?
Not inukare.
Inukare janakute ne.
Why?
Ah.
But, you know, I think it's really cool though.
Wouldn't you like to kind of be able to help harvest the rice?
I like to try harvesting the rice.
Not just harvesting though, I like to try planting too, you know.
It seems fun.
More experiences, right?
Right, you have to get into the field and have a little watering.
Ah, but there'll be frogs.
Ah, there'll be frogs.
Ruffians, please let us know if you see Pero around again, okay?
Remember to let us know using the hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, we have some good news!
Something important to share!
Over the weekend, our first cover song, Kaibutsu, reached 2 million views!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for all your love and support, Ruffians!
Thank you!
We worked really hard on recording.
It was really tricky, right, Mococo-chan?
It was!
Yeah, we put a lot of our emotion and feeling into it.
It was a bit of a new experience.
Right!
Lots of harmonies.
We wanted to do something a little bit different from your song, right?
We challenged ourselves, but I'm not sure Ruffians, maybe you remember, maybe you don't, but when it first premiered on the day that we debuted, there was a translation that actually FUWAMOCO did for it.
We wanted to share the meaning
We hope that you'll listen to it lots and lots, and hopefully our feelings can reach you through our voices that way.
Don't wait, don't wait!
Thank you for the congratulations!
Thank you, Ruffians, for listening to it lots and lots.
No, maybe we're a bit silly, but we put a lot of thought into our delivery and how we wanted to deliver certain parts of the song.
Even if we can't have a translation, we hope that those will reach you in the heart and the brain.
We're really excited to release our next cover song too.
We hope that you enjoy that just as much as Kaibutsu Medical Show.
Right?
Next time's gonna be a little bit of a different challenge, right?
Challenge.
Thank you, ruffians!
BAU BAU!
We have some more good news for you, Moco-chan.
Ruffians.
De-den!
There's no misunderstandings!
Can we still say that?
We can, you know!
Even though you made us start a minute early.
Yes.
We went another day without any misunderstandings.
Apparently!
Aren't you proud of us, Ruffians?
You're proud!
Why?
You're proud.
The nose I'm seeing means, yeah!
Right?
You know, yeah!
FUWAMOCO did it!
You're proud of us, right?
They did it, right?
I keep on saying no way!
No way!
You're not proud of us!
You're not proud.
I'm so proud.
Tears.
So proud that I moved to tears, Moco-chan.
Happy.
You know, we're gonna do our best to keep this streak up.
Right?
We'll do our best, right, Moco-chan?
Yeah.
Less misunderstandings.
That's good for everyone, right?
Good for everyone.
But I'm actually a bit concerned, though, because we're playing card and phone with all of Average today, so... No misunderstandings!
Could be a bit risky.
It'll be good.
No risk, no misunderstandings.
We're good.
Thank you, Ruffians!
I'm so glad, you know.
The Ruffians look so proud.
All those tears.
Proud yet devastated.
BAU BAU!
Well, well.
Actually.
Well, there wasn't a misunderstanding, but...
We wanted to make a formal apology, Ruffians.
It's not my apology.
And it wasn't a misunderstanding.
Maybe I have to make a formal apology, right?
Right, you're gonna apologize.
So, the other day, Fuwawa misspoke and said something.
You know, while we were playing Kanji de Go, we were doing our best to read lots of complicated kanji, right?
So, naturally, there's some 4-moji-juku-go that showed up, right?
Yeah.
4-moji-juku-go.
It's sort of a Japanese compound word that consists of four kanji characters.
And a lot of times it's idioms.
So, like for example, you know this one.
Huh?
It looks complicated, but it's not.
It's not that.
Yeah, we have it in English too.
It's two birds with one stone.
You know what?
The first kanji is for one.
The next is for stone.
The next after that is two.
And the last is bird.
So it's not hard!
It's super easy, right?
Kill two birds with one stone.
It makes sense.
Two birds with one bee-bullet!
But the hard part.
Yeah, they have really good meanings though, right, Moco-chan?
It's really beautiful.
Yeah.
But that's not the part that Fuwawa messed up on.
Ms.
Bulg was actually saying YOMOJIJUKUGO.
And she referred to it as... YOMOJIJUKUGO.
I told you to repeat it, Moco-chan.
I'm just trying to clear up.
You're supposed to apologize, not me!
What does that mean, Moco-chan?
For a character who out-is ladies or nothing.
You should be ashamed.
Ashamed!
The ruffians are laughing at you too!
What do you have to say?
Well, you know, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for my horrible, inappropriate slip of the tongue, you know.
Japanese language is really beautiful.
It should be taken very seriously.
But I get that it's sometimes hard to say some things right.
It's hard to say.
Just like, dog curry.
Dog curry, yeah.
But I hope that, you know, all the 4-10-5s can forgive me, you know.
They're cool!
It's BAU!
You know, Ichigo Ichie!
You know, Jyurin Toiro!
They're cool!
They're cool, but you make sure your tongue is okay.
No more mess-ups.
I'll do my best.
Good!
Apology accepted!
You good now?
I don't know, you have to ask the kanji.
Understood!
I'm good.
BAU BAU!
Kind of have a bit of a confession to... A little bit.
It's a bit hard to talk about, so that's why we're gonna confess to you today, Ruffians.
Ah, Moco-chan, can you talk about it?
Because it's... It's very difficult.
Okay, so... I guess a few FUWAMOCO Mornings ago, I can't remember how long ago, but we talked about our game consoles that Ruffians have.
But we actually didn't include a certain one.
To be honest, it was kind of on purpose.
Yeah, it's painful to talk about.
Yeah, it's a bit painful.
It was our Sega Dreamcast.
There's many reasons.
That we don't think about it.
We try not to think about it the best we can.
Don't talk about it.
And we really love it!
I loved it!
And you know, the Dreamcast is just somewhat of like a dream-like game console, and we'd really like to play it more.
We would have liked to play it more.
But yeah, we try not to think about it.
Dreamcast.
We don't know where it went.
It just disappeared.
It was really special to us.
Not just something you can buy and replace.
It was a special ToriCastle.
So, we're not gonna think about it.
And that's why we didn't mention it to you, Ruffians.
Because we didn't want to make you sad about it either.
We tried not to think about it.
It's difficult.
It's hard.
Thank you for understanding.
Understand?
Well, Moco-chan, you know, it's a new week.
It's a new week, let's forget about that.
And you know, it's the start of a new week.
We're gonna make it a good one!
Right, Ruffians?
It's gonna be a good one!
So, you know, I think it would be good if we challenged ourselves to do something new.
Right!
Something...
Today, Moco-chan, you're gonna be challenging once more
Eat natto!
Ruffians, you know, maybe you're not too sure what natto is.
Maybe you've heard of it, but what was that again?
It's a common breakfast food in Japan.
It's fermented soybeans.
It can be rather sticky and slimy, a bit strong smelling, but it's really, really, really, really healthy for you.
I want to eat it, but... It's difficult for me.
So Moco-chan is going to conquer her dislike for it.
So you know, Moco-chan, that way you can continue to protect the ruffian smile for many, many years to come.
Just like me!
Just like Fuwawa, you know?
Just earlier, before FUWAMOCO Morning, we were able to call in Polka-senpai.
Poruru-oneechan.
Right, she's gonna go to sleep.
Yeah, before she goes to sleep.
And we talked to her about natto.
Yeah, Pororo-nee-san likes natto.
Yeah.
So then, I said, you know, today, I would eat the one bean for Pororo-nee-chan.
I'm sort of worried.
Oi!
Did you... Get ahead of yourself, Moco-chan?
I have to make sure I swallow it.
But for the onee-san's sake, why?
Why?
Well... Okay!
Moco-chan.
First, before we eat it... Before you eat it.
I can't eat it?
This is Moco-chan's challenge.
I'll eat it.
Don't let her down!
Don't put pressure on me!
But first...
Let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi who worked very hard today.
Thank you, I'm gonna eat it.
Not for the farmers in Tochigi, but for Poruru-oneechan, okay?
But I'm sure you'll make the farmers and tochis very happy too, you know?
Today, I have my tissue.
I'm in control of the tissue.
I'm not Fuwawa.
I'm gonna try not to get this over with.
But I'm also sad because it's not my favorite chopsticks.
I don't like the texture of these chopsticks so I don't use them.
But everything else is dirty.
Why are you- Why are you not supposed to- You're not supposed to stir it up!
No!
I made a little bit of a hole.
You have strings everywhere!
By not having a tare.
Tare is for the weak.
It's not supposed to be stirred up.
No soy sauce.
And if you stir it up more, then it gets like, more slimy, more sticky, but healthier too because the natto, the natto... What do they call it?
The natto... Natto Bacillus Bacterium gets all...
Activated!
No, I need to be in control.
No, you're ready!
You're ready!
I'm not gonna feed you, Moco-chan.
No, please don't.
Those days are over.
It's so sticky!
It smells so good.
Can you first lick this off for me, please?
I'm not gonna lick it!
You should lick it, Moco-chan.
No, I don't want to.
Can you please?
I'm not!
Why'd you do this to me?
I have to!
Oh, gosh!
The chopsticks are all natto.
Natto, you know?
Okay, gosh.
I have to do it for Poruru-oneechan!
Take that one bean.
It's Poruru-oneechan's happy face.
It's Porco!
Right!
You see it?
I see it!
Moco-chan, don't make that face.
You can do it!
Strong boy dog!
Why?
Okay.
Ruffians.
Should I chew it?
Yes or no?
I think you should.
Nobisa!
Nobisa, you can't eat Mococo-chan's nut.
She needs to eat it.
Yes?
Chew it!
You gotta make sure it goes down your throat this time, okay?
I'm eating it for Poruru-oneechan!
No tissue!
No, I have tissue!
I need it for my lips, okay?
But I'll chew it for the ruffians, okay?
Oh, you're gonna eat it for Poruru-oneechan, right?
Yeah.
Should I chew it with my... Chew it with what?
The back of my teeth!
You're overthinking this, Moco-chan!
I need to think about it!
You're getting yourself all scared!
I need to think about it.
Yeah!
Stalling, right?
I'm not stalling!
Moco-chan!
FUWAMOCO Morning is gonna end at this rate!
No.
Okay.
I need my heart to be ready.
Please!
No, don't count!
Don't count!
Not yet!
It's not.
No, no, no.
You smelt it.
Don't make that sound.
That was a mistake.
Moco-chan!
Okay.
Can you have water for me ready at least?
Just at least.
Only if you actually drink something.
If I swallow it then, okay?
Okay.
Promise.
Okay, I have it ready.
I wish it was tea, but it's just water.
I have it ready.
You promised, right?
I promise.
I don't want to throw up.
Moco-chan, that's so weird.
I'm just being realistic, okay?
I'm trying!
Don't think of that.
Think of Polka Onee-san.
I'm trying!
Okay.
Three!
No, ten.
Ten.
I need ten.
Okay, Ruffians, all together.
Ten!
Nine!
Eight!
No, no, slower, slower, slower!
1, 10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1!
Oh!
Oh, the string is... Is it tough to Moco-chan still?
Oh, she chewed it!
She chewed it!
Oh, she's making that face.
You did it!
I did it!
Water!
Water
What are your thoughts, Moco-chan?
Is this one bean?
Chewing it was wrong!
No, it's stuck in my teeth!
Take this!
I'm not gonna take your chopsticks!
I'm gonna drop it on you!
Don't drop it on me!
Every time I try to push it off my teeth and my tongue touches it.
She's good.
She's safe.
She did it.
But she's complaining.
She's complaining.
What did she eat?
She ate natto.
Fermented soybeans because it's really healthy for you.
And her older sister Fuwawa likes it.
And her, I guess...
I did it!
Moco-chan did it!
Okay, but I think you should eat some more.
No!
Really?
Okay, well next time, you have to eat at least three, okay?
One for me, one for Poyokani, and one for Ruffians.
Okay, we decided.
Good job, good job!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, that seriously took too long, though.
I did my best.
Can't keep the ruffians waiting for you to eat the natto that long.
BAU BAU!
Oh, look at the natto color!
It's super sad!
BAU BAU!
All right!
I need to cough it up.
Cough it up?
Well, that's not as healthy as the natto.
We're going to today's regular segment!
Today's Doggie of the Day!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
It's Tobi!
Tobi just had an important surgery.
Ruffians, can we all wish him a big get well soon?
Get well soon!
Get well soon, Tobee!
Tobee, Tobee.
Although I bet he has cute two beans.
Get well soon, get well soon!
It's never fun to be healing and need to have a big cold around your head after.
It's uncomfortable, right?
Right, Ruffians?
But you know Tobi, Tobi's making it work with that big smile.
What a trooper.
Good job Tobi.
Well how does Tobi BAU BAU?
I don't think you know.
He's not really a complainer you know.
Not like Moco-chan eating natto.
But maybe Tobi has a big strong confident BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
B
Can I have tweets today?
No.
No tweets.
Good luck to all this time!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Moco-chan went to a Ruffian school this time!
Let's see!
De-den!
What's this?
A block party?
It's so nice, so harmonious.
Look at the skies, the trees are so lush.
You know, it just looks like a wonderful day.
Does a block party mean that there's ice cream?
That's what Ruffians said.
There's music, yummy food, ice cream, and even a bouncy castle.
Did you go on a bouncy castle?
I wanna go on a bouncy castle!
Moco-chan, we have to be careful though, because... Aquas, you know?
Okay, we won't pop anything.
Yeah, no popping.
Just bouncing.
Just bouncing, you know?
But we're really happy you had such a great time, and you were able to connect with your neighbors too, from the sounds of it.
In case you didn't know, we get really shy, so we always try to avoid any neighbors in the Northwest Passage, but...
You're stronger than us.
Why?
Brave.
But you know, we hope that you're able to get closer to everyone and maybe create an even stronger community together.
You know, I've always thought that having a garden with all your neighbors would be nice.
Something with, like, flowers that you can just sit around in and just enjoy a good book in the middle of it so they're both hidden.
I feel like we could get rid of the neighbors part and just, like, replace it with the ruffians, though.
That would be much, much, much better.
Thank you very much!
BAU BAU!
Did any Ruffians have a question for us?
I think so!
Our question of the day is... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I just booked flights for a 26-day trip to Japan in mid-April!
Wow!
This will be my third time there, but I'm going with my parents for the first time!
Nice!
Good memories!
Wonderful!
Can you recommend where we should go?
Mister Donut is already on my list.
Good, good, good!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Well, you know, it's April, so obviously there's hanami, but it's kinda close to the end, so you might wanna go north to Hokkaido to try and be able to catch it, but even then, you know, hanami is more like a...
Now in March, right?
Yeah, it's moving up a bit.
Right.
But you know, there's only Shinjuku Gyoen you can go.
You can get some obento and be able to enjoy the nature there.
Very quiet even though it's in Shinjuku.
There's also Sky-chi, like the Sora-machi.
Sora-machi is the mall below Sky-chi.
Sora-machi is really fun and Sky-chi is like the big tower.
But I feel like we've never gone up to the top.
It's kind of scary.
If you're on a 26 day trip with your parents, then maybe you want some time just to do your own thing, and maybe they want some time to do their own thing.
So Soramachi is good because there's so much stuff, so you can go look at whatever you want, and they can go look at whatever they want.
There's lots of shopping to do there, but also only shopping you can do there, too.
And then also, Sky Tree is pretty close to Asakusa.
So you can start with Asakusa and then go to the Nakamise, the shopping street.
There's a lot of different things you can get there.
Fun things to eat, too.
Make sure you don't do tabeyaruki.
Don't walk with the food.
You have to stay at the place.
And then you can go see Sensoji Temple, too.
It's always awesome.
And then after that, you can walk to Sky Tree.
It's a little bit of a
It's a nice walk too.
And of course you know Tokyo Tower.
Just because Tokyo Tower is not as big as Skytree doesn't mean that Tokyo Tower is not good.
The only thing that's sad about Soramachi is that there used to be a Mister Donuts there and it's not anymore.
It had a big bond of lions.
It did!
But no more.
Tokyo Tower is really fun too.
Probably if you're going with your parents, you probably want to not go to Akihabara.
Just because they're probably not really interested in the Akihabara thing so much.
Unless they are.
Unless they are, but that would be surprising.
Nakano Broadway is pretty cool.
There's a lot of different subculture, pop culture anime and stuff too.
You might find that kind of cool.
Lots of different Manarake stores.
Lots of things to look at.
Right?
It's a bit of a different kind of look into subcultures in Japan.
There's some interesting ones, actually.
But we can just check out.
Right?
Right!
Not Harajuku, I would say.
Especially on weekends.
They're probably not too interested in that.
I don't think your parents would be impressed with that.
It's really busy at Harajuku, right?
So... Yeah.
Oh!
Also, you could do, like, Ichinichi Taiken.
Like a one-day sort of experience sort of thing.
Yeah, like a special class kind of thing, you know?
Something that you could only do in Japan.
There's lots of things like that, but if you just do Ichinichi Taiken.
Yeah, you know?
And then that way you can make really special memories all together, so... Only things that you can do then.
We hope you have a really good time!
Lots of time to do lots of fun stuff, right?
Good memories.
I hope you have a really, really good time together.
Thank you!
Ruffians, don't forget, we're always looking for more submissions.
You know, there's three FUWAMOCO Mornings a week.
So, eventually, you know, your question might be answered.
Your Doggie of the Day might be featured.
You know, your walk.
We want them!
And questions, too!
Questions, questions.
I'm sure you have questions.
We'll be waiting, okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
And our next stream, we have... That is Garlic Porn with Elfen.
It's our first time playing Garlic Porn all together.
Maybe there's some Ruffians that don't know what Garlic Porn is.
It sounds a bit confusing.
Right?
It's not Garlic, thank goodness.
It's like a drawing game, like a telephone game.
Yeah, a drawing.
Maybe Moco-chan says natto.
Or Nerissa eating natto.
Yeah, so then Biboo has to draw what Nerissa eating natto looks like and then it kind of goes from there.
And then you keep on guessing what the drawing is.
It's really fun.
But I'm a bit nervous because I don't want to be exposed to be the least skilled at drawing member of Abyss.
But yeah, there's lots of different modes, right?
Do you think Ruffians will be okay?
Will you be there to support me?
If there's lots of different modes, you'll be okay at some point, right?
Really?
Yeah.
No.
Humble?
I don't think I'm being humble.
As long as they're passionate, well, passionate is something we're both good at.
I'll be there to join, so it'll be okay.
Both Moco-chan and I will be both joining today, so please come and watch and join in on the silly times that will definitely be happening.
Let's take another look at our brand new schedule!
This week we have a lot of collabs and exciting things going on!
I think Moco-chan and I both were really excited for the collabs with Calli-senpai and Fubuki-senpai!
I'm very happy to be able to collab with some of our senpai.
Of course we like Alvin, but... Right?
Are you sure?
Yeah.
We'll be playing Smash together with Calli-senpai on Wednesday.
And that will be on her channel.
Don't come here looking for it.
But I think, you know, our goal is to make her growl, you know?
We're going to kind of team up on her if we can, right?
We want to show, you know, just how strong our bond as twins are.
But I do think Calli-senpai probably has more experience than us, right?
We're going to do our best.
Yeah.
And next on Thursday after that, we're going to be visiting Fubuki-senpai's home again in the back.
Yeah, we already went once.
You remember, right, Ruffians?
Yeah, but we're happy though because you know, Fubuki-senpai's shown a lot of our senpai around before, so we're excited that she's willing to do that account for us, right?
Don't think about the not good things.
Hopefully we won't be scared this time, but... She'll be holding our hands, so it should be better, right?
Right?
FUWAMOCO's holding our hands.
We have to make sure they're not sweaty, right?
Deep breaths.
Lots of deep breaths beforehand.
But we hope that you join us, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
Our Curious!
BAU BAU!
Mahiro!
Takana!
BAU BAU!
Quentin!
Desu Puli!
BAU BAU!
Yan Yan!
Miss!
BAU BAU!
Scoochoo!
Linkle!
BAU BAU!
Hattori!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!